today we're exploring the deep ocean and  it's rarely seen creatures  my grandfather Jacques Cousteau was  always looking to chronicle the wonders  of the ocean at the giant isopod is one  of the most fascinating and strange  looking these crustaceans live thousands  of feet beneath the ocean surface  typically between 500 and 7,000 feet  deep they can grow up to 2 feet long but  this one's just a baby the reason  they're so big is due to something is  due to something called sea gigantism we  don't know why this happens it might be  due to deep ocean pressure or to  scarcity of food resources either way  these guys are huge they're carnivores  and they have four sets of Jaws but can  go for years without eating are you guys  eating you barely lasted an hour one  isopod in captivity in Japan survived  five years without eating okay give me a